folks really don't want a swingers club
outside their home what they do is
strictly a monk and sending the dose
behind closed doors if you're a small
business owner you've probably
familiarized yourself with local zoning
laws these laws allow the government to
say who can build what and where but
what's to stop the government from
creating laws targeting a specific
business one Nashville lawyer is using
the arbitrariness of zoning laws to
fight back against what he sees as
government overreach basically my
feeling is if I own my property I can do
with it whatever I choose Larry Roberts
is currently representing his client who
wants to open up an adult swingers club
on their own private property the
problem the property backs up to a
private Christian school for a five or
six year old as their mother or father
what a swingers club is that's an issue
they shouldn't even have to consider or
confront do they become adults
Ricky Perry is the principle of
Goodpasture Christian school and is
leading the charge to keep the swingers
club from opening so what's his biggest
fear that students will be physically
harmed by the swingers club members
we're not worried about that it's really
the spiritual aspect of affecting a
child's mind and really polluting their
mind with what we feel like is ungodly
activity Roberts client who wished not
to be named bought the property at 5:20
lens drive in a community right outside
of Nashville back in November at the
time of the purchase the property was
legally zoned for private club use if
you think the building is a little
boring on the outside you're right
Roberts client promised the community
that there would be nothing visible on
the exterior of the property indicating
that it was a sex club they also
promised that the club would only
operate on Friday and Saturday nights a
time that would not conflict with school
hours unsatisfied Goodpasture took their
complaints to the Metro Zoning Board and
emergency laws were quickly created that
outlawed private clubs within a thousand
feet of churches schools or playgrounds
Roberts client would have to take his
business elsewhere I think that we have
to be kind of protective of the
community and
respectful of what they want to see in
their community Councilwoman Karen
Bennett pushed for the emergency city
zoning amendments her amendment removed
four zones in the county from permitting
Club use Nashville has allowed clubs as
a permitted use in in Davidson County
since 2006 in that time since 2006 and
none of those clubs have put in a permit
for the for zoning uses that I removed
from the code as being allowed locations
well none except the swingers club the
zoning law specifically targets my
clients and you can certainly interpret
it that way
I think zoning laws are arbitrary in
many instances I think they are designed
to control the community just how
arbitrary are these laws and the new law
says that that my clients can't operate
a private club in that area but it does
not affect their ability to operate of
church there that's right the swingers
club has found religion it will now open
up as a church called the United
fellowship center people can go and
engage in fellowship they will still be
able to dance to meet new people but
they won't be able to engage in any
sexual activity there if they are of a
mind to do that they will have to go
someplace else the floor plan is
basically the same they just changed the
names for example the dungeon became the
choir bell room another dungeon room
became the choir room the United States
Constitution says that Congress shall
make no law respecting religion or the
Free Exercise there are they can't tell
you what is or is not a valid religion
you don't have to go and get the
government's approval there is no
requirement that you get a tax exemption
otherwise the government would be in
control of your church metro zoning
agrees and has said that they must
legally take United fellowship at their
word that they are a church and allow
them to open later on if there are legal
complaints brought against the church
then there is a precedent for the courts
to rule on the sincerity of a belief and
not the actual belief itself but Roberts
doesn't think it will come
to that for all practical purposes my
clients will be a church and they will
have many of the same rules that the
churches observe such as do not steal do
not lie do not cheat do not harm others
do not kill there is one rule however
the difference for many traditional
churches do not commit adultery with
anyone without your wife or that your
spouse's consent and knowledge so what's
the difference between a swingers club
and a church when it comes to zoning it
may all just depend on the words that
you use